welcome to Geary's five best drop most
amazing moves of all time and we're
gonna in this video look at five
miraculous moments where Geary plays a
fabulous move to get a decisive
advantage and Geary is planing the
candidates obviously everyone jokes
about him being a draw master as he drew
all of his games last time around but he
has real style and people forget just
how tactical he can be as we're gonna
see in these five short examples do like
and subscribe to the channel now we're
starting with a nice easy one for this
first one and one I hope a lot of you
get a typical pattern here
Gary forces check mate white to play and
win can you find the right move well
free is often a magic number and that is
the case here white has free attackers
and with the move Queen takes f7 check
checkmate is forced and this is a very
common idea the point being if rook
takes Queen we continue with the most
aggressive and forcing moves checks rook
e8 rook comes back and now Bishop comes
in and we finally deliver this
background check mate so very nice stuff
there from Gary we have a very
double-edged position for this second
example and the giri likes to fight if
you just think he plays boring draws all
the time that's not true and this
position shows that both Kings are in
great danger and in these kind of
positions is often the side which has
the tempo that should cause the most
damage and look for forcing moves and
that's exactly what Gary does here can
you find the move rook to h8 check and
this is a beautiful way to trap that
black King in the corner it has to be
captured and now Bishop takes f7 keeps
that King trapped on the hairy file
where it can't escape with a white rook
or a white queen coming to deliver
make very soon black try Bishop takes be
to check with some ideas of opening the
B file but Giri just has to avoid the
checks and he does so by sliding the
King to b1 and black resigns as there's
nowhere to run to anymore and here we
see Giri Duffing up more as a [ __ ] a
very talented player of his own right
and he's gone sacrificing through a lot
of this opening start of the game and
how he comes up with another below the
black King clearly in danger and we need
to keep applying pressure to that piece
how can we do so look for the checks
look for the captures Bishop f6 check
and I love this move seemly putting the
bishop on a square where it can be
captured but of course if it is captured
the White Queen slides in with
devastating effects even taking the rook
next move with mate but maybe even
better as this one actually rook to c8
and after Bishop f6 check more as a
witch tried to block that one but you
can see just how bare the king is on d8
and now the Queen slides in Knight d7
trying anything to block the checks and
a very cute move Bishop to d4 this
bishop been the old important piece and
the idea is to come to b6 or after rook
to c7 Queen to a eight with checkmate
next move don't underestimate Gary's
attacking power when he's given a chance
he can be as good as anyone in the world
great players have great vision and they
can see tactics that the mortal humans
and mortal GM's among us very mortal
cannot often see and that is the case
here Gary has a lovely arrangement of
pieces and a deadly pawn on f4 but how
can he cash in on these positional
assets can you see the move he played
Bishop takes h3 very forcing move and
this is finding a way through to the
White King and in the game against Nyssa
theano a very strong player from Romania
Grandmaster white simply played Queen C
free and admitted to being a pawn down
went on to lose the problem is if the
bishop is taken the F porn now moves up
to f3 only once squared to move the rook
rookie free and now g5 is not covered so
the black Queen can slide its way into
glory on g2 very nice little tactic
they're just showing what makes the
difference between these guys and some
of some of us some of us normal kind of
patters finding seemingly impossible
moves making them work is a skill that
some of the top players have and that's
exactly what Geary does here he has a
safer King better development than black
with the black King being stuck there
but he needs to find a way to get at
that King you know he needs to get rid
of the door get through the door rip it
apart how does he do it
c4 and this seemingly impossible move is
opening up the positions so it might not
look like a deadly tactic but I really
like it from the visual side the point
is if black ever captures with a B pawn
it allows the Queen into b7 and the
Queen will rampage over on the Queen
side if D takes c4 Knight takes e4 will
come or even Bishop takes and the same
thing happens so a very nice move
forcing the opening of the position the
game continued Bishop takes f3 Knight
takes F free and our pawn takes c4 and
simply Bishop takes c4 again this can't
be captured because the Queen coming in
black tries to develop some of his
pieces and now a very nice couple of
moves from Geary
you still need to force away through to
that King and it does this by playing
efore using his central majority Bishop
e7 Bishop c1 gaining a very useful tempo
Queen a5 and now d5 lovely play forcing
more lines to be open and he goes on to
win in a mere 23 moos great vision there
from Geary in an interview for one of
the leading publications in the chess
world Geary who's were known for his
drawers and
cept in drawers he got all drawers in
one candidates was asked who his
favorite musician rapper singer or band
was to no one surprised he answered 50%
and in this position rather than giving
checkmates with rook to h2 he decided
that he would prove that his answer was
correct and he played rook g7 giving
stalemate now I do joke about giri and
his drawing tendencies which is a little
bit unfair after watching a number of
his games he's actually extremely
exciting play a very capable of
excelling and doing well even winning
the candidates do you agree of me we all
got to have a bit of a laugh and we know
giri has a great sense of humor thank
you for watching this video do like and
make sure you subscribe to chess comm
check out the website where they have
more premium videos you can learn lots
of opening and other things there and
I'll try to continue with this series as
long as I get enough likes and
subscribes